the tax the rich dress designer whom aoc
went to the met gala with owes over a
hundred grand in back taxes received a
forty thousand dollar ppp loan has
legions of unpaid interns owes sixty
thousand dollars in workers compensation
and still found 250 thousand dollars for
a table at the met gala
now a couple of things right out of the
gate one
fact we know that this is the designer
of the dress the tax the rich dress
two i personally don't know i don't know
john if you know if this was aoc's idea
or if this was the designer's idea could
have been aoc saying hey i want a dress
that does this the designer just does
what they're asked or it could have been
the designer's idea probably not that
important of a detail but i want to call
it that i don't know the answer to that
the third thing is
owing back taxes very relevant detail
here
the ppp loan i actually don't think is
that important right it's look the
government offered a program you want to
go take a loan go take a loan you either
have to pay it back or they end up
treating everyone the same and certain
people didn't have to pay it back
whatever if somebody needs help and they
are offered it and you want to take it
that's up to you so i actually don't
think the pvp thing is that big of a
deal but i understand that people will
yell and scream about it say hey if you
owe taxes you're taking money from the
government yeah yeah whatever
legions of unpaid interns this actually
i spent 30 seconds googling around and
supposedly there are allegations
important allegations that the designer
uh was allegedly running the equivalent
of a sweatshop i think was the exact
terminology that i read
which employed legions of unpaid interns
now i'm not from the fashion industry i
know it's confusing i'm very fashionable
so it might be surprising to some that
i'm actually not an expert on the
fashion industry but it wouldn't
surprise me if the fashion industry is
one of those industries where unpaid
interns is actually still the norm
rather than the outlier i don't know
that for sure but uh when people start
to say you have legions of unpaid
interns legions is a pretty uh
inflammatory emotionally driven word i'm
assuming that that person is biased
on top of that when people start to use
the term sweatshop uh here in the united
states hard for me to believe that it's
a true sweatshop i've seen the
documentaries of things like in china
pretty bad conditions so i'm gonna
basically say that this is likely to be
uh you know somebody who has said look
they're not paying people enough money
they should pay them more et cetera okay
let's take the data point for what it is
and then owes 62 000 in workers
compensation i don't know what that uh
essentially is who that it's owed to how
factual it is and then found 250 000 for
a table at the met gala my guess is that
the table was not paid for that it was
either a ticket that was given or the
met gala i think i'm on to them they got
a lot of people showing up to the met
gala
that don't seem to be buying the tables
so i'm wondering if the megalo just puts
these radical prices out there and says
if you're rich you pay for the few
suckers that actually pay yeah
if you don't get an invitation you pay
but if you get an invitation wink wink
we gotcha just come in the door here's
your ticket you don't pay so that's my
guess is what's going on here uh i can't
imagine that uh they're actually paying
for the 250 000 for the table but hey
who knows somebody can correct me if i'm
wrong so the important part though and
the part that i do think
smells of hypocrisy uh and is a fair
critique is owing a hundred thousand
dollars in back taxes but then running
around with the dress whether you're the
designer etc saying tax the rich
there's a lot of hypocrisy there that's
where i think people say wait a second
hold on what are we talking about here
right if all of a sudden people aren't
actually paying their taxes right
assuming that this is accurate if
they're not paying their taxes how can
they yell and scream at other people to
pay more taxes than they already owe
because we're not talking about oh the
rich people uh have back taxes to pay
and they're refusing to pay them we're
not yelling and screaming and saying
that the rich people uh aren't paying
taxes what we're yelling and screaming
about is
tax the rich more the more part is the
the part that gets left off it's not tax
them because they get they pay no taxes
it's not tax them uh in the sense
they're not paying the taxes is we
should tax them more which again maybe
you believe in that maybe you don't i'm
not here to judge whatever you want but
what i do think
is really tough pill to swallow is when
you say tax the rich but you owe 100
grand
that to me like now we're entering into
the hypocrisy zone and i think this is
the part where people just say look you
lose credibility if this is really what
you believe
and then these details come out people
lose credibility in the conversation
because they just say
like
what i don't know john what do you think
like this like this to me just is it's
weird
yeah i want to reiterate that we don't
know if these are true right um i have
not seen her tax returns i have not seen
what what is going on in that situation
i think if she owes money and then
created a dress with collaboration with
whoever it is uh saying
tax the rich i think that's a ridiculous
thing to do um and i want to reiterate
the staff that we said last week one
in 2018 the top one percent of taxpayers
paid more income tax in the bottom 90
combined it's look it's not tax the rich
it's tax to rich more and that was very
very well said um like this it's it's
almost comical
it really is so
rather than tax the rich as you guys all
know from last week i have a better idea
we even created a t-shirt around this
idea is i don't want to spend time
complaining yelling and condemning
success i don't want to attack the
successful people i want the successful
people to tell us
exactly how they did it so we can go
tell the 90-plus percent of americans
who aren't going to have enough money to
retire
i want the 80 percent of millionaires in
america who inherited zero dollars to
tell us how they became millionaires so
we can go teach and actually create
financial education for the people who
aren't millionaires yet for the 33
percent of millionaires in america who
never earned more than a hundred
thousand dollars in a single year
i want them to tell us how they did it
and what the principles around personal
finance they used so we can go teach
everybody else how to do it
all boats should rise together we should
educate the entire country so that more
people can benefit here rather than
trying to condemn success when you
condemn success you rip away hope of
people who want social mobility and so
what we can do is by educating people by
empowering them by giving them the
information
anyone in this country can become
financially secure hey guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today and don't forget to
check out our partner sofi they make all
this possible they're a super app that
lets you save spend borrow earn and
invest all from one single platform and
if you go there today and you sign up
for a sofi invest account you can get
between five dollars and a thousand
bucks for free from sofa not everyone's
obviously gonna get a thousand dollars
but everyone gets something don't say
that i never did anything for you go
check them out at sofi.compomp
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.compomp
and make sure you come back and watch
more of the best business show we're
going to build the biggest business show
in the world and we need your help
[Music]